make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay Brian Michael Bendis had my
curiosity and now he's got my attention
and you guys will find out why at the
end of it at the end of this video but
uh yeah like that the cliffhanger did
this comic leaves us on is like nuts
it's just like holy cow and then we have
to wait to like March 13th before the
next issue comes out and I'm kind of
dying that's one of the downside with
bindus he writes so much stuff like
everything becomes a monthly series when
he writes it instead of it being like
bi-weekly you know so it's kind of like
all right that sucked but uh okay so the
return of Jonathan Kent the return of
Superman's son now like we talked about
the last video Superman's son was kind
of taken on this journey through the
galaxy by by Superman's father jor-el in
order to give him a better understanding
of his place in the cosmos and when
Superboy returned back to earth of
course he was about five years older he
was sixteen I'm sorry seventeen years
old as opposed to eleven years old he
was six years older and really been
discounted seems to be using this first
arc or I guess really this this existing
arc of Superman to kind of tell us what
Jonathan had been doing in the time that
he was out in space but the issue is
that Jonathan comes along and basically
says dad your father is insane
like you know jor-el of Krypton is
insane now this is kind of the cool
thing here and the reason why Jonathan
sort of comes to this conclusion at
least it kind of seems to be hell on the
nose here is that jor-el sort of
questioning his existence and this makes
sense right he's basically having like
an existential crisis because jor-el is
a guy who was rooted in science right
like by all standards of measurement
jor-el should be dead he was supposed to
have been killed when Krypton exploded
now we as the reader know that dr.
Manhattan yanked him out at the last
moment with Krypton blew up just to kind
of see what happens presumably just sort
of see what takes place to just kind of
watch how the pieces unfold and so on
and so forth this kind of this big grand
experiment what jor-el doesn't know that
as far as jor-el is aware just some
higher powers basically saved him from
the destruction of Krypton and he can't
explain it now this is the reason why
jor-el has this existential crisis
because when he's talking to Jonathan
and when Jonathan's asking questions he
only says you know like why did you
choose to come here and all I kind of
get stuff and Jonathan's talking about
how he's here for the purpose of like
understanding the galaxy and things like
that jor-el be against a sort of hit of
this idea that like it was a mistake to
bring Jonathan and the reason why is
because the two of them were on a sort
of mission of self-discovery in and of
themselves where Jonathan is there in
order to understand his place in the
cosmos to understand how insignificant
earth is in relation to like everything
that goes on in the galaxy and the
greater universe jor-el is there in
order to kind of
find answers but what he does is yes
Jonathan what if there are no answers
and the reason why is because jor-el is
a guy whose entire life was immersed in
science right I mean kind of moving away
from the comic for a second looking at
jor-el as as he is jor-el was a guy who
was immersed in science I mean he was he
was like the scientific mind on on
Krypton he was the one who knew Krypton
was gonna come to an end he was the one
who told the Kryptonian Science Council
we have to do something to stop it but
he was also the guy he was considered to
be full of heresy and full of nonsense
and ultimately dismissed dismissed by
the Science Council only for them to
realize how stupid they were when the
planet blew up and well I guess Ben has
kind of changed that with rogles are I'm
sorry business but that was a stupid
idea
but if that remains here that that with
this whole thing but jor-el is a guy who
comes from the concept comes from the
ideology that everything can be
explained by science right and that's
really the nature of the Kryptonians but
Kryptonians didn't really believe in
like gods and deities he didn't really
believe in like a power outside of their
ability to comprehend and explain
everything could be explained through
science religion was kind of reminiscent
of a bygone age right right you know
religion is a byproduct of people's
inability to explain what goes on around
them so they just chalk it up to
religion and just call it a day it's a
lazy man's explanation whereas science
basically says there has to be a reason
why this exists let's pursue it too it's
in and find out what it is and if we
can't find an answer that means we have
to push our knowledge further until we
can the pursuit of knowledge is what
gives existing knowledge and makes a
society better
that's how Kryptonians viewed themselves
but with jor-el he looks at what's going
on kind of looks at his existence and
says I should be dead and some higher
power that I can't explain that is not
manifested itself to me save me from my
own destruction in the face of a
possible deity out there I'm kind of
left with no real answers he's literally
rigid and structured unable to adapt to
the fact that saw that something beyond
science exists out there that basically
resurrected him you know at least saved
him from his own death now that's
Joelle's perspective we are again we
know dr. Manhattan was one who did it so
there's a scientific explanation a giant
blue guy who could manipulate atoms and
walks around with his penis hanging out
save jor-el from being killed like we
know that explanation is there jor-el
just doesn't know and so it's kind of
crazy when it when it comes to this full
scenario but what is done is it's throne
jor-el into an existential crisis caused
him to question everything around him
and because that is just kind of like
what's even the point of anything
anymore and that's kind of the funny
scenario here is again so rigid so
structured unable to adapt and at that
moment Jonathan Kent sat down and
I have to get out of here like I've got
to leave this place this guy's just a
crazy to basically you know she's kind
of going on these inane ramblings and
and so on and so forth there's really
nothing to him at all so again it's kind
of intriguing here but again with with
Superman and Lois really putting
Jonathan Kent through the rigors more or
less testing his DNA testing his brain
patterns and verifying that he is
actually Jonathan Kent of course that
being verified is actually being the
case then what he basically does is he
essentially says now I have to tell you
the rest of the story you guys want to
know what happened I will tell you what
happened what Jonathan says is after a
while time just kind of seemed to blur
together and the reason why is because
Jonathan Kent's understanding of time
was relative to like the days passing on
earth right like it's Monday we know
that because that day is called Monday
the Sun sets the Sun rises now it's
Tuesday and so because of that when he's
out in space out in the rigors of space
when you're flying through you know and
the Sun doesn't really rise or set the
days just kind of blur together after a
while
not only that it was constant
distractions there were always missions
to go on there was always somebody out
there needing help for Jonathan Kent and
for for jor-el to go out and assist and
face off against whatever the case may
be and so because that was always going
on there were constant like blood
Jonathan just sort of lost track of time
and so some amount of time had passed
and it's really Brian Michael Bendis his
way of saying it doesn't really matter
here and in reality it doesn't it
doesn't really matter how much time had
passed you know in this particular
instance because what matters is what
actually went on behind the scenes and
what was going on behind the scenes is
that in this you know event that
involved you know the thanagarians and
involved like the Green Lantern Corps
with with Jonathan meeting Kilowog and
me arisia is it's cool to see this
because he's basically meeting like
members of the Corps that he would never
meet right like Jonathan's you know his
understanding of the Green Lantern Corps
is limited to like Hal Jordan in like
the one time he met him as though
outside of that like the Green Lantern's
are just kind of these beings who exist
out there not only that it's kind of
cool because when when Jonathan's
talking about this you know when he's
meeting with the Green Lantern's and
he's talking to them they kind of
consider Earthlings to be a hassle right
like look you know all our things what
we do is screw things up because we're
really not that advanced they're
basically you know a primitive race
fumbling and bumbling their way through
the universe causing more problems than
they are helping anything
not only that Superman's really the only
earth thing they know which kind of
makes sense because Superman's really
the only one who leaves earth and
travels out there outside of like Hal
Jordan John Stuart kya Guy Gardner and
Kyle Rayner so for the most part all
they really know is Superman but it's
interesting because with Jonathan being
Superman's son that is kind of okay
we'll give you a little bit of leeway
here but again for reasons that
aren't necessarily explained here jor-el
seems to be you know kind of hesitant
about the idea of of Jonathan running
into and meeting Green Lanterns and in
turn spends what seems to be like a year
never talking to Jonathan doesn't say a
word to her then just kind of leaves it
to our own our own imagination here I
mean what kind of left to assume they
never really met they never really did
anything that is kind of free floated
through the galaxy for about a year or
so or maybe they went on missions we
don't really know but Jonathan talks
about how he had basically listened for
anything that was coming from Earth any
bit of news anything like that and
didn't really get anything and again
that makes sense because when you're
talking about the greater universe the
greater galaxy and in DC Comics earth is
exceedingly primitive right like you're
talking about a planet of people who
have just barely scraped the surface of
like interstellar travel humanity for
the most part is sitting like men to the
moon they've they've taken one step
towards the door they haven't even
gotten outside yet whereas you're
talking about racism in various
civilizations out there that can travel
the space ways move exceedingly fast
travel from one side of the universe to
the other your turn I mean you're
talking about like a whole other civil
like a whole other side of the cosmos
out there that's way beyond what earth
is technolon you know technologically
it's so with humanity being so primitive
and being so basic there really is
nothing out there there's really no
reason for anyone to ask any questions
about Earth because no one really knows
anything about it and if they did from
what Jonathan tells us the only thing
they know is Superman so again like it's
really having no idea what's going on
his immediate surroundings having no
idea what's really going on with regards
to like earth and in someone and so
forth how things are progressing and so
while Jonathan and jor-el are making
their way through you know whatever the
cosmic we know whatever is going on at
the time and jor-el begins to address
Superboy what he does is he basically
says you know I'm I'm sorry for what's
about to happen and the inclination
seems to be here at leaf from what Brian
Michael Bendis does is he seems to toy
with the idea that jor-el did this on
purpose that he basically flew them
towards a black hole and the Superboy
was caught in the vortex and ripped out
and it seems to be intentionally done by
by jor-el
we don't really know why we don't really
understand that's exactly the case but
it would certainly go towards the idea
that Joelle's lost his mind now this is
what I say Brian Michael Bendis most
certainly has my attention the reason
for this is because when Superboy
basically flies through this black hole
and ends up on the other side that what
he does is he crash-lands on this giant
place somewhere but then he's met with
the arrival of the crime syndicate of
America Superboy
Jonathan Kent has basically traveled to
a different dimension and ended up in
earth 3 he's at a different universe now
he's
literally left one universe and travel
to another he's in earth three where all
the heroes are villains and all the
villains are heroes I'm actually very
excited to see what happens next
I know a lot of people are gonna ask
questions like well isn't the crime
Simek is supposed to be dead you know so
on and so forth sure I guess witness
Brian Michael Bendis he just kind of
does what he wants to and we have no
idea if he flew through a black hole and
went back in time we won't know until we
actually find out in the next story
undoubtedly people are going to kind of
jump to conclusions and assume their
opinions are right I don't know I'm kind
of curious to see where we end up going
here but without being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here too comments explained make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]